We always talk about CAR-T versus bispecifics, and in reality, it's both.
We use both.
But the comparisons are always, well, CAR-T is hard, and it is.
I mean, I want to die most days by the end of the day because of all the manufacturing
issues we've had, all of the out-of-spec.
I mean, there's so many things that can happen.
And again, the access, right?
The number one issue with these therapies, especially CAR-T, is access.
And if you can just give the actual gene therapy to that patient, and you can figure out a
way to make the T-cells in that person without having any manufacturing, not needing lymphodepletion,
that could actually change everything.
So I think this is really exciting.
There's actually other CARs that have already been tested as well.
There's a paper in Lancet with a different in vivo BCMA CAR last June.
And so again, brand new data with like four patients each.
So there's not, you know, I don't have a lot of clinical data for you, but lots to think
about how this is going to go in the future.
So again, differences with ex vivo CAR-T versus truly in vivo, it really eliminates all these,
you know, things like pre-conditioning lymphodepletion, the logistics become so much easier.
The culture doesn't need to be there.
All these things that can happen when those cells are in culture goes out the window.
There's other things that can happen, which is my last slide, but reduced cost of goods
and manufacturing.
We talk about price, right?
And so again, this could actually really change all of that.
So this was a Kaelin.
I have nothing to do with this study.
This was done in Australia.
And Dr.
Joy, you're welcome.
Dr. Joy Ho presented it as a late breaking, which I was really excited about because it's
CAR-T, but I was also surprised because it was for patients, but I was still excited
that we had two late breaking at ASH for myeloma.
So again, this is a modified LVB generating anti-BCMA CAR-T cell.
So there's an envelope modified LVV in terms of the viral vector, the lentiviral vector.
There's a detargeted VSVG.
I don't know everything about this stuff, the physogen, but this really helps.
The biggest question is how do you get this to T cells, right?
Inside your body, not go to other organs.
And so again, this is sort of how they were able to use ways to avoid things like the
liver.
So again, T cell redirecting, because you have the CD3 SCFE.
And then again, they went after BCMA as the antigen.
So there's a lot of science in terms of how do we actually get this to the T cells and
again, the right T cells.
And I don't know the answer to that.
But this was the in my car trials.
This is a first in human phase one study that was done in Australia, and it starts with
6 million to two times.
It's kind of the seventh, seventh cells per kilogram.
And again, they had four patients so far, and then they have further dose levels that
they'll look at and expansion cohorts that we'll look at as well.
So these were not patients at a prior BCMA.
They were triple class exposed and then adequate organ function.
And then basically they looked at overall response rate and CAR-T cell expansion and
persistence, which was some cool data.
Okay.
So these were the four patients.
So again, most of the patients were in that.
One patient got the dose level one and then dose level minus one one for these folks.
And again, all of them are refractory to at least a doublet, but potentially triple class
refractory.
You can see they had some high risk set of genetics, and we had patients from 61 to 72.
So a little bit older, but in general, everyone had ECOG performance status.
So most of these patients had three to five lines of therapy.
And I think every single one of them, because it is Australia, had prior auto transplant,
which again.
And might be different if this was in the US.
So here's some of their translational data in terms of what happened.
So, you know, this question about absolute lymphocyte count, are we seeing it in the
blood and myeloma?
You know, some of our CAR Ts do, some don't.
Here we did.
So there was at least one patient that really, you know, that third week.
So the expansion happens later, right?
Because again, you're not taking a whole bunch of cells you've made, put them into a patient
and, you know, wait for that CAR to really kill right away.
You're putting in the transgene, which then has to find the T cells, which are the transgene.
Which then starts growing those T cells.
So again, most of the expansion happens in that third to fourth week.
And that's where you see it.
And again, most of these were CAR positive cells for a lot of these patients.
So I think one of these studies will show, one of the slides will show sort of the safety
piece of that.
So again, what they're able to show that they did have persistent memory CAR-T cells in
terms of the types of cells that they were able to see.
And for time, I will skip that, but you'll see the slides and then again, most of these
patients have responded.
So it's 100% response rate and they are still all ongoing in terms of their response.
One had reached CR, the rest for PR, but likely will hopefully have improved results long
term.
And then you can see that soluble BCMA question that came up earlier that yes, when patients
have active disease, we see it.
And for all four patients that started decreasing once they were responding.
So again, safety, what was really surprising was there was no ICANNs or delayed neurotoxin
again for patients, but even their CRS was grade one, two.
So again, that's a little bit of a surprise.